[Música]
en agosto de 1947 India obtuvo su
independencia después de 200 años de
régimen británico luego ocurrió una de
las migraciones forzadas más largas y
sangrientas de la historia donde
murieron un millón de personas antes de
la colonización británica el
subcontinente indio era un mosaico de
reinos regionales conocidos Como
principados habitados por hindúes
musulmanes sijistas jainistas budistas
cristianos parsis y judíos cada
principado tenía sus propias tradiciones
tipos de castas y liderazgo
a comienzos del siglo 16 una serie de
potencias europeas colonizó la India con
establecimientos comerciales costeros
para mediados del siglo 18 English is
India Company energía como la potencia
colonial principal los británicos
gobernaron algunas provincias de forma
directa y los principados indirecta de
esta forma los principados eran
soberanos pero debían otorgar
concesiones políticas y financieras a
los británicos en el siglo 19 los
británicos empezaron a clasificar a los
indios por su identidad religiosa una
burda simplificación consideraron a los
hindúes como mayoría y a las demás
comunidades religiosas como minorías
diferentes siendo los musulmanes La
minoría más grande los sijistas eran
considerados parte de la comunidad hindú
por todos menos ellos en las elecciones
la gente solo podía votar por candidatos
de su propia identidad religiosa estas
prácticas acentuaron las diferencias que
sembraron desconfianza entre que antes
coexistían el siglo 20 trajo décadas de
movimientos anticoloniales donde los
indios pelearon para independizarse tras
el fin de la Segunda Guerra Mundial bajo
una enorme presión financiera los
británicos finalmente se dieron los
líderes políticos indios tuvieron
visiones diferentes de cómo debía ser
una India independiente
y querían una India unida Mohamed Ali
Gina que lideraba a los musulmanes veía
heridas de la colonización muy profundas
abogaba por la división en dos naciones
donde la de los musulmanes se llamaría
Pakistán con los disturbios de 1946 y
1947 los británicos apuraron su salida y
planearon la independencia India en
junio de 1947 El virrey británico
anunció que India obtendría su
independencia en agosto y que sería
dividida en India y Pakistán musulmán
Sin dar una explicación exacta de cómo
ocurriría con base en mapas viejos
censos incorrectos y conocimientos
somero del territorio en apenas cinco
semanas el comité de límites delineó la
frontera que divide a tres provincias
bajo la regla directa británica bengala
punjab y asam la frontera consideró
donde los hindúes y musulmanes eran
mayoría además de factores como
ubicación y porcentajes de población
Entonces si un área de mayoría hindú
tenía frontera con otra igual se
incluían la India pero si el área de
mayoría hindú tenía frontera con áreas
de mayoría musulmanas se hacía parte de
Pakistán los principados en la frontera
debían elegir con cuál de las nuevas
naciones se quedaban y perdían su
soberanía mientras el comité de límites
trabajaba en el nuevo mapa hindús y
musulmanes empezaron su mudanza a las
áreas donde creían que serían parte de
una mayoría religiosa las familias Se
dividieron ante el temor a la violencia
sexual padres enviaron a sus hijas y
esposas a regiones que se percibían
seguras el nuevo mapa no fue revelado
hasta el 17 de agosto de 1947 dos días
después de la Independencia las
provincias de punjab y bengala se
convirtieron en las separadas Pakistán
Oriental y occidental el resto en India
de mayoría hindú en dos años millones de
hindúes ysistas que vivían en Pakistán
se fueron a la India y los musulmanes de
India huyeron de lugares donde sus
familias habían vivido por siglos las
ciudades de la ore Delhi Calcuta daca y
karachi se vaciaron de antiguos
residentes y se llenaron de refugiados
en el vacío de poder que dejaron los
británicos milicias radicales y grupos
locales masacraron migrantes mucha de la
violencia ocurrió en punjab y las
mujeres se llevaron la peor parte por
violaciones y mutilaciones casi 100.000
mujeres fueron obligadas a casarse con
sus captores los problemas creados por
la partición llegaron más allá este
efecto mortal muchas familias que se
mudaron temporalmente quedaron
desplazadas permanentemente y las
fronteras continúan en disputa en 1971
Pakistán occidental se separó para
convertirse en bangladesh Mientras tanto
el gobernante hindú de cachemira decidió
unirse a la India una decisión que se
concretaría con un referéndum Público de
una población de mayoría musulmana ese
referéndum aún no se ha concretado a
2020 y la India y Pakistán siguen
peleando por cachemira desde 1947 más de
70 años después el legado de la
partición sigue Claro en el
subcontinente en sus nuevas formaciones
políticas y en la memoria de las
familias divididas
si deseas seguir aprendiendo sobre
momentos determinantes en la historia
mire este video que detalla los 13
tensos días de la crisis de los misiles
cubanos o profundice en como adolf
Hitler y el Tercer Reich llegaron al
poder en la Alemania democrática con
este video